Race relations are better since I graduated, that's the truth.
No, my election did not create a post-racial society.
I don't know who was propagating that notion, that was not mine.
But the election itself and the subsequent one,...
...because the first one, folks might have made a mistake.
The second one, they knew what they were getting.
The election itself was just one indicator of how attitudes have changed.
If you had to choose a time to be,...
...in the words of Lorraine Hansberry,...
..."young, gifted, and black" in America, you would choose right now.
I tell you all this because it's important to note progress...
...because to deny how far we've come would do a disservice...
...to the cause of justice, to the legions of foot soldiers,...
...to not only the incredibly accomplished individuals...
...who have already been mentioned,...
...but your mothers and your dads, and grandparents...
...and great grandparents, who marched and toiled and suffered...
...and overcame to make this day possible.
I tell you this not to lull you into complacency, but to spur you into action...
...because there's still so much more work to do,...
...so many more miles to travel.
And America needs you to gladly, happily take up that work.
You all have some work to do.
So, enjoy the party because you're going to be busy.